So now let's dive into actually creating our cinematic sequence.
So one of the first things that we want to cover is we essentially need to create our master level sequence.
And to do that there are a couple different ways that we can create that actual sequence.
So we can do it through the main toolbar or we can do it directly within our content browser.
So if I jump back over to our scene and if we go down to our...
I'm going to open up my content browser here.
So we want to start with underneath our content courses sequence 105 under maps.
We want to start with the sequence 105 game dev.
So if you notice that we don't actually have any of our content here as we have with the default map that opens.
And this is going to be our starting point.
All right. So the first thing I could do is I can go up to the main bar and do add level sequence,
which in this case it's going to create a new level sequence asset and place it in our level.
I'm going to come back to this in just a second.
Or I could go to my content browser and I could simply just come down to my sequence 105.
Let's go and create a new folder.
I'll just call mine class.
Double click to go into it.
I can right click and I can do animation.
I'm sorry cinematics level sequence.
And essentially it's going to do the same thing.
Now the difference is if I create a level sequence within my content browser,
you'll notice that it's not actually in my world.
So if I go ahead and delete this real quick.
Go back to the main toolbar, add level sequence,
and you'll see that it'll request for me to put it in a certain location.
So go back up to class.
We'll keep the same name.
And you'll see that it creates the level sequence and it adds the level sequence directly in our map.
So this is one of the first things to keep in mind when it comes to creating your level sequences
is that those level sequences don't have to be placed in the level.
Now essentially the reason why we don't do that is the level sequence is itself a container.
Now one of the things to keep in mind though is you may want to place it in the level
because at any point, so I'm going back to my content browser, right?
This is an asset.
So we can open it up anytime within the project and it'll be fine.
The issue becomes though if this particular sequence is designed to interact with content
within this particular level, this is a situation where putting this sequence in the level itself may be advantageous.
And what do I mean by that?
Well, if I don't have, so if I delete the cinematic sequence from my level,
you'll notice inside of our outliner, so if I kind of roll some of these up,
you'll notice that that sequence is not present.
However, in our content browser, it's available.
Of course, double click it, it opens up the sequence, roll this up and we can continue working with it.
Now, because again, the sequence is going to use content within this specific level,
having it present in a level actually makes a lot of sense.
So even though I deleted it from the level, I can simply just drag this into our level
and say, for example, put it right here.
And you see that the sequence is present now in the outliner.
And really all this does is that if we ever have to come back and modify the sequence,
again, let's just fast forward in time through development.
Let's say that we have hundreds of sequences.
If there's really no naming convention or something that tells me that,
oh yes, this new level sequence is designed to work within this particular level,
by simply just having it in the level, so just this little icon here,
I can simply open level sequence and I know that it's intended to be used in that particular level.
All right, so just keep that in mind.
Again, not necessary, but for this example, we'll go ahead and just place it in the level so we have it.
So just a couple of things to keep in mind when it comes to our assembly.
Now, I am going to caveat that the process of us building this entire sequence out,
we are going to be putting everything into a single sequence.
Now, for full-up production, I don't recommend this purely on the it's important,
and we'll cover this in other classes.
It's important to keep your content separated,
especially if you're working with a distributed team or working with various different departments
that would be involved in this shot creation.
Let's take, for example, lighting, animation, VFX, camera movement, characters, etc.
Having everything nested within a single sequence can get very, very messy,
and not to mention the fact that you run into issues with source control
where only one person can have that file checked out.
So just throwing the teaser out there in other classes,
we talk about nested subscenes and being able to break those out,
but for the purposes of today's class,
we're simply just going to put it all in one level sequence.
So with it, you'll see that we'll start assembling our cameras.
We'll assemble our characters.
In fact, let me just jump over to the sequence itself.
So I will jump ahead real quick to this 905,
and you see this is the final assembly.
So this is what we're going to be building towards.
So here's our cameras.
Here are all of our cameras nested within a folder.
We have our two characters that will be present.
We also have some lights that only appear during our dialog
and then our events track.
So everything will be nested within a single sequence.
So I'm going to close that sequence out,
go back to my content browser, and open up our new level sequence.
And then we'll add various different things like a fade track
or adding different colorations just for organization,
but we'll do this at the end.